el primer ministro británico pide
disculpas boris johnson reconoció ante
la cámara de los comunes que si asistió
a una reunión de más de 100 personas en
downing street en mayo de 2020 su
gobierno prohibía encuentros de más de
dos personas por la pandemia
cuando entré a ese jardín poco después
de las 6 del 20 de mayo 2020 para
agradecer al personal antes de volver a
mi oficina 25 minutos después y seguir
trabajando cree implícitamente que se
trataba de un evento de trabajo
y quiero repetir que pensé que era un
evento de trabajo agua que vengan
9 y lo lamento mucho lamento mucho que
no hicimos las cosas de una manera
diferente de ese anuncio le daré m
sus opositores se burlaron de los
argumentos de premier y piden su
renuncia
stefan su defensa de que no se dio
cuenta de que estaba en una fiesta
[Risas]
es solo píxeles es tan ridícula que es
en realidad ofensiva para el público
británico
[Aplausos]
cuando todo el país estaba encerrado el
estado organizando fiestas alcohólicas
en downing street ahora va a ser lo
correcto y va a reiniciar el show
el evento de la polémica fue citado por
el secretario privado de downing street
martín reynolds él envió un correo
electrónico pidiéndole a los asistentes
que llevaran sus bebidas pero no es el
único escándalo que ha enfrentado el
gobierno de johnson existen
investigaciones internas por otras siete
posibles fiestas de funcionarios en
pleno confinamiento johnson sólo ha
aceptado la última reunión que se
conoció